do not look for approval
except for the consciousness
of doing your best
the first man gets the oyster
the second man gets the shell
when you really want something
the law of attraction comes into play
wealth is not to feed our egos but to
feed the hungry
and
to help people help themselves
do more
the race is won by the horse that
outstrips its rivals by a head
if you want to get rich
think of saving as earning
i resolved to stop accumulating and
begin the infinitely more serious and
difficult task of wise distribution
people who are unable to motivate
themselves must be content with
mediocrity
no matter how impressive their other
talents
no man becomes rich
unless he enriches others
it marks a big step in your development
when you come to realize that other
people can help you do a better job
then you could do alone
the man who dies rich
dies disgraced
gathering wealth is one of the worst
forms of idolatry
no idol is as destructive as the worship
of money
surplus wealth is a sacred trust
which its processor is bound to
administer in his lifetime for the good
of the community
anything worth having in life deserves
to work for it
if you want to be happy
set a goal that commands your thoughts
liberates your energy
and inspires your hopes
he that cannot reason is a fool
he that will not is a bigot
he that dare not
is a slave
all human beings can alter their lives
by altering their attitudes
perhaps the most tragic thing about
mankind is that we are all dreaming
about some magical garden over the
horizon
instead of enjoying the roses that are
right outside today
control your finances
or lack of them will control you
do your duty and a little more
and the future will take care of itself
as i grow older i pay less attention to
what people say
i just watch what they do
there is little success where there is
little laughter
i don't believe in god my god is
patriotism
teach a man to be a good citizen and you
have solved the problem of life
the best way to become poor is finding a
job that will suck the life out of you
aim for the highest
if you don't want anything for a long
time
most likely it's time to start working
all honors wounds are self-inflicted
friends are for the eating and drinking
but not for the business
ninety percent of all millionaires
become so through owning real estate
the best portion of a good man's life
is little
nameless unremembered acts of kindness
and of love
rich people avoid two things in life
stupid environment and stupid spending
i believe that higher wages to men who
respect their employers
and are happy and content are a good
investment
yielding
indeed
big dividends
the duty of rich people is to set an
example of modesty
and not be arrogant
i am a speck of dust in the sun
and not even so much in this solemn
mysterious
unknowable universe
no man
will make a great leader
who wants to do it all himself
or to get all the credit for doing it
no abilities and opportunities matter if
a person is well to do
every act you have ever performed since
the day you were born
was performed because you wanted
something
concentration is my motto
first honesty
then industry
then concentration
when showing mercy
one must adhere to the main principle
help those who are able to help
themselves
a library outranks any other thing a
community can do to benefit its people
it is a never failing spring in the
desert
you must capture and keep the heart of
the original and supremely able man
before his brain can do its best
don't rest content with the fact that
you have done your duty
the one who does not do what he is told
and the one who does no more than what
he has told
will never break through the top
the fastest way to double your money is
to fold them in half and put them in
your pocket
the men who have succeeded are men who
have chosen one line and stuck to it
we have tried to collect andrew
carnegie's quotes that will always take
care of your hunger for the gains of
success his quotes are a huge category
with a plethora of empowering life rules
and words of wisdom to keep havoc at bay
thank you for watching